hey guys big announcement my special
Lefty sun will be dropping Wednesday
April 5th on my YouTube it's free go
watch it support it like it subscribe I
shot it here in LA in December at the
dynasty theater and I'm really proud of
it so go check it out April 5th
Wednesday Lefty sun on my YouTube
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night past
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler and all your
social media and I want to say thank you
thank you for all the love thank you for
the support thank you for all the love
and support of this show uh I'm telling
you subscribe please if you're watching
hit it up it helps us out and also keep
an eye out for my new special Lefty son
coming out working on it post right now
probably a couple weeks but don't worry
I'll be hyping the hell out of it just
wanted to give you all a heads up now
and if you gotta have more then you
gotta check out the patreon all right
it's called the Honeydew with you all
and every week I say it and every week I
am literally Blown Away by the stories I
hear the submissions that come in it's
five bucks a month you're getting audio
you're getting video you're getting a
honeydew a day early you're getting it
ad free all for five bucks a month all
right
um dates we're going into this easy now
so I'm starting to go back on tour but
not till late May because I got this
whole lung situation which we're about
to get into here shortly uh but may 26th
and 27th I'll be in Fort Wayne Indiana
June 23rd and 24th I'll be up in Tacoma
Washington July 7th and 8th Appleton
Wisconsin July 21st and 22nd Tulsa
Oklahoma probably going to swing by
Eskimo Joe's you know what I'm saying
now you guys know what we do over here
we highlight the low lights I always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers well unfortunately today
that's going to be me so I'm going to
introduce my guest hosts ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome back to the
Honeydew Daniel Van Kirk welcome back to
the Honeydew young man I play good to
see you good to see you good to see you
literally
um all right before we get into
everything that we're going to talk
about because you're going to interview
me about this whole situation
everybody's been asking me about it
we're going to just put all the
information out there because there's a
lot I don't remember there's a lot I
remember
I remember things you
didn't know
uh oh before you begin all right please
plug and promote everything dvk uh a lot
of people know I do a podcast called
dumb people town uh a lot of people need
to know I also do a podcast called pen
pals pen pals is a show with me and Rory
Scoville and we get letters from
listeners about anything could be
honeydew moments could be pineapple
moments pineapple's the inverse of this
show I always feel like it's strawberry
strawberry Strawberry strong yeah you
know uh some strawberry moments it could
be anything people send us letters and
then the way we write them back is
reading their letter on air and then
giving our response that drops every
single Wednesday and that is uh the pen
pals pond with Rory Scoville myself and
then live dates
what I have coming up April 14th in
Houston Texas it's would you rather
comedy uh we start out the show by
asking the audience like would you
rather just for fun and then uh Comics
throughout the night when they come up
they may get asked would you rather I
always do one as well it's a great way
to do new material have fun the audience
knows that you have no idea what it's
going to be about
um that's a great show so that's it the
secret group secret group hdx.com and
then at the end of the month the last
Saturday of April I will be in Denver
headlining with the growlx boys uh yeah
so Andrew oval overdoll Ben Roy and Adam
Caton Holland so that'll be awesome
everything's at danielvankirk.com
well
um the reason we're doing this is
because there were two people who were
well three that were predominantly there
the lower time I was in the hospital the
Holy Trinity
uh yourself Michael Duffy and Roy right
those are the yeah they were there a lot
Good Old Roy marks Good Old Roy marks
all your business management needs and
um
so let me set up why all this happened
so we're gonna go all the way back this
is your Gilligan's Island this is
supposed to be three hours supposed to
be a that's yeah bro it was supposed to
be a three-hour tour
what's crazy you said that to you
multiple times in the hospital I made
t-shirts you you know what let's go
to the place
[Music]
oh good my three hours
so um but I mean you're all the way back
okay we go to we go to high school okay
we're gonna go back to Liberty [__]
high school where this injury starts for
myself you know this I know for a fact I
I mean I I know for a fact because we
had a class called weight training okay
and weight training in our highest all
powerless was yep right on the wall 300
bench 500 squats yep and if you could
bench 300 it didn't matter if you Bank
your [__] backwards you were getting
on the wall we had a machine called the
attacker and you stood in front of it
and had handlebars like this or
handlebars like this and you push the
weight with you I'm sure there's a
correct way to do it yeah but nobody's
telling a 16 year old in Rochelle
Illinois in the halls of rths a school
that was built the end of the 1800s how
to push this thing I mean yeah
500 pound Squad so they're not teaching
you form it's be strong don't be smart
right that's what they're saying they
don't know how to position
you're like I have pneumonia and I don't
think I could play today but why are you
being gay man like that's what the 80s
were like you're being gay right now
like what I'm I have I'm sick
I have a friend played quarterback right
in high school he gets concussed so bad
he runs to the sidelines finds his way
there says uh I can't see
I'm not gonna say witch coach
they said great we'll just do a run play
a dummy because he knows two steps back
turn left so he's out here running
like Lucas the movie without the glasses
so yeah That's how little they cared
about so you get it that's why they
cared as much as they knew they just
didn't know enough right right
so
um I get injured and sweet doing the
squats yep for sure doing the squad and
you know it's your lower back oh I'll
tell you so I continue like a [__] to
play sports because I'm young and dumb
and full of come and you can't tell me
and it finally catches up to me which is
crazy for people like us because we got
people dying all around us and we still
literally we're gonna live yeah yeah
so I finally go see a physical therapist
right like how old are you I'm s what
injury was like 16 and then I finally
wait till like I can't run anymore my
left leg is not playing soccer my coach
is like I can see you Galloping like
what's going on so they make me go
you're pulling out I Get Physical
Therapy
um but I go to this chiropractor first
and that was a mistake because this guy
no joke his name was Dr Adolf when I
pulled in I was like this is not good he
I swear to God a lot of a lot of them
went to Baltimore
he also uh was the Baltimore Colts uh
chiropractor okay so this dude used to
[__] snapping and yeah Big Bubba
Smith and [__] yeah Bert Jones you know
what I mean Johnny Unitas yeah art
Donovan not my little [__] six
remember that James Harrison with the
acupuncture yeah remember that from Hard
Knocks he's got like 600 needles in him
yeah so this guy's used to that that
type of man okay you know and I go in
and he snap crackles and Pops my ass and
it I'm hurt so bad I crawl up the stairs
to go out of there like oh God oh God
I'm like oh so then I go to physical
therapy like yeah chiropractor is all
wrong from you he actually irritated
this you have a slip disc it's
protruding it's deteriorating that's
what's going on so I start Physical
Therapy
um and they put me in traction which to
this day
I wish I had enough money to buy I'm
gonna make it a goal to buy a traction
table really dude I've never done it it
slowly pulls your body yeah yeah oh it
feels so good really like if you could
just have you know those invert tables
they don't work as well but if you could
hang from something I have a non-sexual
fantasy of being hung like this yeah
yeah pulled apart and then twisted like
a [__] Wash Rack create a little
space and then just break up that card a
little bit yeah
that ends up working I come back my
senior year I play half the year of
soccer I get honorable mention all
Central Maryland I go on to play
you know my junior college all juggle
all Juco [__] soccer all this [__]
with this [__] pain still that's at a
five six for constant are coming and
going constant ly every [__] day
we're like a level six every day of my
life right okay
so finally after 35 [__] years of
this [__]
um it starts to catch up to me now well
I've had like there'll be there was a
whole time where I couldn't I couldn't
get out of bed I would I would move what
felt like millimeters in my car seat
just to sit so I wouldn't cry and could
drive to work and not kill people or
myself on the road like back pain is
literally crippling so
um I I start doing epidurals and you
can't you can't do them a lot the doctor
tells me like look man you you this is
for pain management it's not gonna fix
your problem it's just gonna get you
back out there for a while and then each
person's individual it might last a year
it might last six months you don't know
this is the type of [__] to like get you
through the day or the second half of a
game amen not life so this dude hits me
with one in the back the first time and
he's like oh and he he ties my leg like
straps my legs down all this stuff and
he's laying FaceTime yeah I have no idea
how epidural works
occasionally in sports and always during
pregnancies right for people who should
they hit you with a bunch of numbing
needles first because it's a [__]
real deal needle and then they go down
and they go right in there where where
the agitated spot that do you just say
it's barking he's like that thing's
barking and maybe if back then when I
was younger I would have got something
like this it would have calmed it down
enough and maybe he wouldn't have
damaged it as much because I'm out there
being an idiot and we're just playing
so um he's like all right we're done and
I start laughing he's like what's so
funny I go come on dude I'm not a kid
like just just let's get it over with he
goes I did do it like a nah he goes you
didn't feel that I go now
he goes all right you're gonna need to
go home and come back again and see me
in a week and I go okay I come back the
next week
how long ago is this
2006. oh wow that's when I first started
getting the maintenance
and um dude he hit a nerve I if I think
about it I can still feel it run down my
[__] left leg
oh vibrate now yeah
so that works it works to get me back
out there for a while if I back out
there you mean driving your car and
walking around 2006. I'm working out I'm
playing on Sports but all in pain every
day pain pain pain but not a 10 not a I
can't sit down not I can't stand the
nagging issue that her [__] crazy ass
pain in my crazy about pain is the
longer you go with it the more you
tolerate it that's right which is bad
for you that's it's good for survival
like in six seven hundred and two
thousand years ago yeah
so um
at this point
um
I have to go get one more before
Stella's born so that first one lasted
me about seven years wow and I get
another one
when Stella's born and that lasts me
right up until this last one here and
what happened was I was I was like I
finally met with this doctor the surgeon
it was great and he said look I don't
it's surgery I don't want to operate on
you
until your quality of life is affected
and I said all right well I'm there I've
done the epidurals the physical therapy
the Pilates I've done the so what is
this
early winter last year end of end of
last year okay so December November
right around there okay and um I've done
the [__] cupping I've done to this
I've done it all
you know someone's like you know you
should try I'm like yeah no [__] really
I should try a massage no [__] Cairo
I've done it all I got a crystal in my
pocket right now
so
I um excuse me
I tell them I've done these things and
he's like okay well then we can talk
about I said my legs are numb so so it's
both legs now that's what happened at
the Troubadour when I headlined the
Troubadour last year it was the first
time in my career I had to sit on a
stool I couldn't feel either
yeah because I couldn't feel my legs
usually if you watch me I'll rock back
on one leg and I'll sit on like my right
hip and just keep the weight off of this
leg just because it goes numb yeah
but now I can't do anything and I'm in
pain and we're going on vacation I'm
about to take my daughter to uh Ocean
City Maryland right you said vacation go
I know we're going to see our cousins in
Ocean City right and the only thing I
can do thankfully now comfortably is I
can sit so I can fly fine I can drive
fine I can sit I can't stand or walk for
[__] damn so that's gonna be a problem
so the doctor gives me painkillers and
he knows he knows I hate him I don't
like him he's like you need to take
these when you need to because you're
not going to get uh fixed until you get
back yeah
so I bring them with me we're out we're
driving we're fine whatever
this is a bit a little [__] this felt
good so uh we do these little they have
Scopes these guys walk around the beach
and they do these pictures and they make
you do all these poses and they'll take
like 20 of them and then the next day or
later that night you go to this place
you pick them up buy whatever you want
or whatever so the next morning we all
go and they're trying you know trying to
sell you on every picture they took well
why don't you get the 10 pack and then
my mom's back there like well I could
get the disc and go to see you're never
gonna go to CVS and do this okay so look
here's the money just just get an and
now I'm in pain and I'm like I'm gonna
go sit down because it's like the end of
the day and that was like morning I'm in
just excruciating pain all I need to do
is sit right okay but it's a building
where you walk in is the the desk and
the money and then you go in the back
and that's where everybody can look at
the kiosks and their [__] right so I go
back and now I'm sitting at the [__]
desk like I'm working at the place but
I'm just sitting there to rest my back
and this young kid walks in and he's
staring at me and he's like I'm sorry
dude you work here like I do not work I
can't answer any questions he goes nah
are you Ryan sickler and I'll go yeah I
am he goes oh my god dude I'm listening
to you on the Honeydew right now I was
like dude thank you so [__] watch my
cousin my mom they were like oh yeah so
we leave and my mom uh texts me when she
gets in the car she's like oh my God
they gave me all everything we talked
about and I was like good there you go
there's your [__] pictures
so now I know I'm coming back and I'm
going to wrap up the tour I shoot the
special Lefty son coming out of my
YouTube channel and um I'm going in for
this surgery right this surgery as you
said is supposed to be a simple
three-hour outpatient procedure supposed
to go in at nine surgery at ten I'm done
by one a little bit of anesthesia
whatever bam I'm out and then you got
the whole weekend the therapy is walking
they want you moving blood flow blood
flow this is on Friday this is on a
Friday I go in right so let's we'll take
a look at our first picture here Kirsten
can we look at the first picture here
that's me right there getting all set up
for my [__] look at simple three look
at it look at the Hope in those eyes
this is who told me
[__] has no idea
this is a man who's gonna sell the
better part of a month laying in bed
talking to me like he's my Grandpa
Grandpa Joe
I'm trying to win a Golden Ticket
that's a man who was promised he would
enter his name he's pain-free you can't
I said to The Surge like you can't tell
man that's going in his 50s he's going
to be pain-free after everything I've
felt all these years he's like you're
gonna be great you know what's crazy too
little did you know you're about to lose
15 20 pounds
that too but also even at this point and
prior to this in all of my paperwork
sure I document
I have a genetic blood disorder called
Factor five life
shut the [__] up yeah and that's right
and the reason I did that is because in
2016 I developed kidney stones my legs
end up clotting they think I have cancer
leukemia they don't know at the time but
you weren't like bedroom you didn't have
some other it was bedridden from the
kidney stones I was I didn't that's what
did it right or brought it to the
surface so it takes six months of being
in and out of hospitals and being a
[__] lab rat to figure out that I've
got this this blood disorder called
Factor five light and now it's genetic
so now I'm gonna tell everybody I'd
never heard this term at all before 2023
this is the word of the year in my life
[__] Factor five Factor five I
literally if I was like you might get it
if I drink every time this [__]
says Factor five
you should do that listen back to this
so
it's genetic and my mother test she
doesn't have my brother test he doesn't
have it I have a twin brother different
egg but this [__] did not get it
right my younger brother doesn't get it
I'm like well [__] I'm the one who got
it and obviously I got it from my dad
right
and then I start thinking about all
right well when he died we know now that
it wasn't really a heart attack it was
these blood clots and everything and we
knew he had him from he did have a heart
attack but he also left the hospital
with clots like I have
um and then it just sucks because you
think man if he would have been if
they'd have known they'd have put him on
blood thinner and he could still be here
easily
um and then going back to being the
person that watched my grandmother
collapse and then give her CPR and mouth
them out all that like I'm like oh
that's probably the [__] woman who
gave this to him who gave this to me
appropriately named special Lefty son
keep an eye out for it on my YouTube so
um to ask your question yeah do you
factor five it's fine it's life
sounds like a healthy protein bar no an
unhealthy one
I got an ego too because I've been
hearing at Factor five light and
lighting line I set it to one of the
guys on the phone he goes you have
Factor five leading and correcting me
like that I was like okay
well I started asking people how do you
say it because it's lighting it's like
you test your daughter for it yeah so
that's where it gets someone I was
curious or do you wait
you have to wait because she's young and
you know yeah the pediatrician said look
until you need to like because pregnancy
a bed rest for pregnancy could kill her
if they don't know she has it right so
could it God forbid she's in accident or
health scare or anything could kill her
if she doesn't know she has it so
um they know I've already made them
aware I have it so also
um we were told that I didn't know this
but birth control for women is uh makes
them prone to clotting so if you have
this you don't take birth control so
there's all kinds of reasons she does
need to know if she has it but she got
time yeah and it's interesting I don't
want to say her name but she's a friend
from high school just in case she
doesn't want her business out there but
her name's Kathy what's up Kathy and her
son I believe is 19 and started having
clotting issues and I said you should
have him checked for this [__] yeah and
lo and behold he's got it and I was like
here's the bad news you gotta get
checked now and she's got it now her
parents have to get checked and she's
got it from both of them wow and that's
when it's bad that's how you know
they're meant to be if you have two
parents it's not good one is okay but
she's also had three kids you know she's
gone through the gauntlet of things that
could really [__] her up until we get
the old age that's right right you gotta
keep that machine moving so
um so you go in on Friday and you're
telling everybody hey I got I got it's
packed or five it's in my paperwork even
the surgeon goes you're really concerned
about that factor five and I was like
uh-huh because I clotted before I
thought you were drugs the first time I
was like he means fact or fiction
okay so you tell them I had ended up
having an interview how much are you
even you're telling them which is good
but we're talking three hours man three
hours this is and it's something
seriously point zero zero one percent of
people have any kind of issues but I
should have walked in to see Babylon the
same exact time you went into surgery
and you'd be out while I'm still
watching
that's what's supposed to happen I'd
already been fluttered by though right
where's two more minutes
all right I beat him I beat him it's
worth it I love them so
uh the reason I was so worried about
this and knew what I was talking about
was because I had I figured out that I
had it before but also I had clotted and
I kept telling them they're like no
you're not I'm like man I'm home there
was a point when in 2016 when I laid in
my bed and gave myself up I knew I was
gonna die I was crying I was ready to go
I couldn't no one would do anything so
finally I go in search of this
oncologist everything my Primary Care
Physician's the one that figured out and
they were like you need to keep that
dude no primary care physician figures
out somebody's got this
so
now I've got it now I got to be aware of
it and I've had no problems I wear my
compression pants on flights I get up
every 90 minutes on a flight I'll walk
to the back I stretch out I'm that idiot
because I have to keep bloodshot I go in
the bathroom so I don't bother anybody
and I do I do quad stretches in there
you can hear me banging like
God I'm doing marches in there and [__]
I know people think I'm [__] mom in
there for 10. I got he's in a fight for
his life yeah it sounds like I am dude
for real I'm in there doing all kinds of
stretches a lot of Garrett's Popcorn
before we took off
it's so [__] stupid so
I tell them everything right yeah
and but also it shouldn't have mattered
that much three hours it shouldn't have
but okay keep going so
I go into the three-hour outpatient
procedure and that day it happens to be
one of the days that's pouring down rain
out here in LA and where this city is so
ill-equipped for precipitation from the
[__] sky
and um I get there at nine like they say
my stepson Derek picks me up takes me in
and uh 10 a.m is when the surgery is and
I'm waiting and 10 comes and goes 11 12.
right one I'm fine I'm like what is
going on out there and this nurse peeks
her head and she's like look I was
hoping you'd already be back there
before my shift was over but
um there's a leak in one of the ORS and
were cramming everyone into the one and
I'm like all right well why am I I had a
10 a.m schedule why am I going later
you'll be going in 30 minutes I heard
that twice
6 p.m
comes around and I'm being taken back
I'm the last [__] one being taken
back
say wheel me back Derek had to go he's
long gone and
um
I [__] wake up
and this is the next picture here if you
want to take a look at this this is what
I see when I wake up okay when I wake up
this is my view now that's that's it
right everyone's gone yeah it's Friday
these lights are out like they're
wrapping another night right these this
this was good cop right here but bad cop
is actually this is bad cop good cop was
over here talking to me there's two
nurses good cop and bad cop yeah [__] is
very Rocky for good cop was the American
lady
this is the Russian over here okay she
might have been checked but at Eastern
when I walked in I heard her say if he
dies
sorry dude
so I'm waking up this is my view mm-hmm
and they tell me hey your stepson can
come back here because everyone's gone
there's literally no one here yeah so he
comes back and sits there
and they're like all right before you
leave you have to pee
and I'm like okay so I try to pee and I
can't pee and I know what's coming
and I'm like you're not putting a
catheter in me and they're like if you
don't pee we are I'm like you're not
you're not right like well we need to go
I was like yeah but it's not my fault
that I went at six o'clock like if I win
at 10 A.M I'd be out by one because how
long of a procedure is it three hours
that's it yeah you could have screwed
around until five hours that's what I
said I could have took five six hours to
take this piss but now you want me to
get it done in 45 minutes right and I
need a little more time to recover you
know what I'm saying your failure to
prepare is not my emergency
[Laughter]
I like that yeah
so um
they're you know bad cop is threatening
to put this thing up my dick hole and
good cops rooting for me she's like come
on just get in there she's like do you
want a heating pad or she's giving me
hot compresses to put on my dick and
balls cold ones I'm gonna give me a cold
one putting everything I can on my [__]
and I feel like it's gonna go but it's
not going anywhere okay and they're like
okay you get one more try and I'm like
no
no I don't
so I get up Derek's sitting right here
he has no idea hospital gowns open in
the back dude I put I just bent over
gave him a little one right in his face
like oh dude I was like you gotta beware
were you sitting at the hospital
you know he's like I don't know him from
the back I'm like yeah
so I go back in and I'm like all right
we gotta [__] get this done because
the the thing they tell me too is if if
they put a catheter up your dick you now
have to pee on your own in 24 hours or
your bladder could explode or you could
die she says and I said
how long does the anesthesia last they
said 24 hours I said it's nine o'clock
what do you think I'm about to do I'm
about to go home and sleep this shit's
knocking me out I'm definitely not gonna
get up in eight hours and pee on my own
like I'm not [__] leaving now that
you said that I'm not doing it
and I go to finally I go what do you
want to go home is that what it is like
your time I'm running into the rush yeah
yeah and she [__] you know how a
horse does that exaggerated that's how
she said yes
and the american ladies over there she's
like no no I go look at her she's not
lying she wants to go give me a nurse
back here that needs the hours
give me somebody that [__] it's got a
car payment or something
oh [__] so what happened so I finally I
go back and because this is all before I
oh this is just this is procedure
so I finally I [__] say
um all right I'm gonna go in and get
this done I can do it I'm doing it and I
[__] go in you know you're talking to
yourself come on [__] come on
and I just start pushing as hard as I
can then I'm scared I'm gonna blow the
[__] surgery out because I'm like
I just start [__] pissing everywhere
I'm like oh yeah
and I'm having that moment in there
where I'm so had I just like oh God and
then I was like is that enough for you I
said it to the Russian she's like that's
plenty so we get out of there now right
now she's Wheeling me out in the
wheelchair this lady who is the Russian
okay and she is the doors are extra wide
bang bang and I was like everything
[Music]
we pee on you
shoves me out the [__] rate
and I go home Derek takes me home yeah
and then I'm by myself for the weekend
the doc the surgeon caught he's gone but
he had gone around each person so I was
very excited to hear what happened to me
and everything and now I'm not getting
that because he's probably out [__]
having dinner weekend yeah
so
he calls me on the next day and he's
like man it was more complicated than we
thought uh the age of the injury you
know what's really going on you got
muscular damage spinal stenosis
decompression was the surgery and what
he tells me is that my my nerves had
hardened because it had been so long and
they wrapped around my spine and they
were squeezing my spine so that's why
now both of my [__] legs are going
numb it's getting there he said there
was leakage he said the L three four and
five those bottom ones had the
passageway was pretty much gone he had
to re-construct those he had there's
some lining around your nerves whatever
that he had to reinforce all this [__]
he's like when you get through this
you're gonna be a new man I'm telling
you and I was like all right so he goes
because of reincarnation
[Laughter]
so he's like
um send me pictures of what it looks
like and I send them pictures of what it
looks like he's a guy so it's not
responding the way it should so instead
of you walking around wait you sent him
pictures on Saturday yeah we're gonna
show him yeah he called me on Saturday
to tell me everything he was awesome
right now you send photos of your
progress on Saturdays the first day okay
we could take let's take a look at these
pictures right here
so this is what it looks like when I get
out of surgery right here okay now
that's not to tell these people what
they're about to see yeah you're about
to see some surgery well they're too
late now that's not terrible it's not
terrible it gets gnarlier but it's not
it looks like you have an Ace of Spades
tattoo
yeah that thing right there that's a
Cancun store we'll cover that part two
what's going on is that just bruising uh
no I think that's like I don't know what
it is to be honest I don't know if
that's like where they Mark me only you
would turn your first post-op surgery
picture into an Under Armor ad you
believe it yeah
okay so now it's supposed to be going
down looking like a normal spine but
here's where it just starts to swell and
then here's one more after that okay
that's where he's like all right this
thing's not doing what it's supposed to
do so now I want you on bed rest and I'm
like all right but remember he's like I
remember we were supposed to walk you
got Factor five line I'm like that's it
but Anne they told you walking is what's
good for this that's what's really good
now lay down so he wants to see me on
Tuesday I go in on Tuesday and he sees
it and he's a guy you're going into
surgery today they admit me to Cedar
Sinai the ER room like don't worry we're
gonna try to give you act you know this
is a different place than where you had
the pursuit I went to the same place
first and they're now sending me to the
hospital Cedar Sinai okay
and I go in and um we're in the ER and
it's again it's pouring down it hasn't
stopped pouring down rain so every
[__] lunatic is in the ER all the
homeless people all the crazies I mean
it's it's a free-for-all and I'm in a
wheelchair and I'm like hey I can't sit
like this I need to lay down is there a
bit now anything in the hallway no
and I'm like yeah but I can't so I'm
showing the nurse is like oh we'll try
to get you in right away
they push me I see them sending me over
to the crazy corner I was like uh-uh
don't put me over there no we'll get to
right here yeah put me in here
I see this guy's screaming at everybody
he's going around hustling people for
loose change for sodas uh we see one
homeless guy and again Derek my stepson
who's been a rock through all this
driving me we see this homeless guy
Striker security guard so now they're
dragging him out like it's it's Mayhem
and I keep begging them two hours goes
by three hours I'm like I can't sit like
can I please I'll lay on the floor over
there like you cannot lay on this filthy
floor I'm like oh my God so six hours
I'll wait
and we finally get admitted now I'm
having the surgery Bing Bang Boom I'm
out again I wake up and they wheel me
into what I call general population that
gem pop area and that is when you showed
up I called you on when there I talked
to you on Wednesday and said I'm coming
tomorrow because you were like don't
come today
oh I know
so on Thursday
I find you you can't even tell me where
you're at no
you didn't know if you were a North
Tower
a floor you're on you didn't know what
bay you were in
I literally had to just find you not
that here you are right here look at you
showed up at the hospital that's where I
was that's
Rochelle I am that's what's on that mask
right there I couldn't [__] find I
didn't know where anything I didn't know
where that was when I walked in
okay so I walk in there and you were
telling me stories
now when does the when does the I don't
know I don't want to step on so so I'm
in an area just just to be clear that is
like I know I'm gonna be there for a
couple days but again now it's just
supposed to be three days I'm supposed
to be in there just to heal this isn't a
room I want everybody to understand it
is it is a curtain it's a nurse's
station essentially
and all the beds and there's like eight
of them I would imagine are separated by
curtains that's it that's it yeah if we
can yeah here's my view right here
there's my cart right there let me tell
you something
get that [__] up button thing
drove me nuts was it you to fixed it who
fixed it it drove me nuts that well I
was like but a lot happens on the other
side of that oh it does yeah but see
when you're laying flat on your back you
don't see anything unless it's high
enough into that mesh area now that's
this is what it looks like on both sides
as well so that's where I am but also
this room I have a lady who I met on my
right named Chandra who had been there
for a day or two and was about to get
out of there but the person on my left
was there for two hours from a thumb
surgery this person was there for three
hours recovering from a knee so it's
they're coming in and out but I'm like a
resident yeah and that's when I start to
hear what I call it a mayor of the floor
over here this [__] homeless guy that
is he's got that you know that oh
extreme voice recording my medicine
and every day this [__] is
screaming well he was screaming when I
got there on Thursday so you'd only been
in there a day and he already had his
fish picked out that he wanted was that
on Wednesday or Thursday or was it
before I got there
it was later because it was it finally
built on me like I couldn't so you know
there's people playing music and [__]
I'm [__] up yeah I know I can't sleep
I can't rest I can't do anything they're
cranking hey it's part I'm only here for
my thumb you know and I'm like what the
[__] and
um also I'm laying there one night and
this poor lady comes in and I want to
say it's because of one of my sponsors
Babble I started taking Spanish lessons
a while ago and I was able to tell that
this lady who on the phone was telling
her family members that she had tested
positive for covet and I only know that
she was crying because they wouldn't do
her surgery and you had to have a
negative kova test to get surgery done
so now she's upset that they're not
gonna I'm putting it all together in
Spanish there's mesh between these
curtain yeah so they start dumping me
full of Dilaudid and morphine to start
with morphine and stuff and I don't
soaring I don't like drugs like sure I'm
weed I'm shrooms once in a while that's
it I don't even drink that much I like
to keep myself close to myself but
homeboy down there has been bugging
people all night and he's screaming if
you're here if I'm Ryan there's one
person to my right
then there's one maybe two to the left
and then it starts horseshoeing it's our
dog legging whatever you want to call it
so if I'm here this person is he's right
right over here right on the turn yeah
he is that's exactly where he is and he
wants he wants everything he [__]
wants that's right
so this [__] is an all-night
two three in the morning all night long
he would nap not so oh oh oh
I need the medicine oh and then some of
the night people were so sick of it they
gave it prison right yes
throw my [__] back I'm flat on my
back I can't do it maybe you're his Andy
Dufresne so and sickler didn't make a
sound that night
he cost me two drops of Dilaudid I sat
there and took it and took it yeah
you're just processing
and then that was when he hit him with
that last one he's like oh what the
tilapia and I just said how the [__] do
you know we get tilapia like I lost it
I'm after day five I'm in there now
the nurse that is ridiculous you're
tattooing yourself
tilapia how specific that is was he
wrong he was not wrong he got tilapia
and I that's when I was saying like I
realized that this gets Wilder I'm
responsible for a life
yes I don't know anything the way a
junkie knows the system sure you know I
should know parents sadly yeah the way a
junkie knows the system and I don't I
don't know anything in life the way a
[__] junkie knows the system this
[__] gets tilapia and I can't
get over it and I'm also starting to
lose my mind because the Dilaudid is now
on my IV and as I told you I'm starting
a [__] hallucinate I'm seeing I'm
seeing your mask flip on and off and I'm
like what the [__] is going on and that
and then I just start to see chunks of
Flesh fall off your [__] face bloody
chunks and I can see the skull behind
your face and I'm like I'm like I'm like
uh-uh I'm seeing I'm having dreams of
guys laser my eyes out and I can hear
the dirt crunch from them in their suits
like if anything if any [__] and all
you want films tilapia oh he wanted I
just wanted to I want to be pain-free
bro yeah wait what do you say about
filmmaker if they could have got in my
head they would have had Blockbuster
we'll get there but you were having
crazy dreams it was frightening
Blockbuster [__] sci-fi Event Horizon
melting stuff and I'm hearing yes puppet
master all of it yeah so
um I'm in there for a while and I keep
saying don't let me clot don't let me
clap finally after like five or six days
somebody comes in and they ultrasound my
legs and they say you don't have any
clots in your legs wait you're dropping
five or six days don't you want to talk
about getting out of there don't you
want to talk about the tilapia dude
getting his girlfriend yeah this is day
two that all happens in there was it
that yeah you see I don't remember being
that early yeah I show up and you are in
the Gen pop area and you're and I I'm
gonna say this to all the dudes and
honeydo's and don'ts out there yeah
he's on every 30 seconds he's like man I
don't even know what you're saying
yes I also show up remember he's on a
three hour tour okay he also thought
when he went back in he wasn't going to
be in there by Thursdays they said yeah
I'm getting out today enough I took
enough like I took a pair of [__] I
took a charger you're lucky for
underwear you're lucky we're Comics
because my backpack just has whatever I
need for flights hotels all this [__] I
gave you Chargers eye masks uh
headphones yeah over the years and stuff
like that because you didn't have [__]
and you also were trying to do the way
you are where you're like nah I'm not
playing I'll get my own stuff I'm like
you're not going anywhere and so you
telling me about this guy and he's
screaming and I'm like okay right all
right yeah sure I know I know and you're
like oh it's things are going on and
then I hear all this commotion
and I look up but wait let me say why
though because I want to set this up so
I brought in three days of my own meds
yeah and I learned that you're not
allowed to do that at the hospital they
want your [__] they'll replace it yes
but we're gonna inventory it we'll hold
it until you cannot I'll give you
whatever you need that you have but they
can't just take your word for it or
whatever in these boxes right and this
guy's girlfriend shows up and she's
being a problem right where you started
you can organize you already know her
purse has never passed her album It's
always kind of around this area and we
keep hearing them say ma'am you can't
lay on the bed so now I'm like oh these
two junkies this is that's before I got
right know the system she's basically
sharing a bed with him because as a
visitor quote unquote because if not
she's got to go through what I just went
through of six hours of this and blah
blah blah and she needs this [__] fix
right
so go ahead so they go through her stuff
right and they say we need to take these
pills if you're gonna be in here and you
told me and I was like Ryan come on
you're like she didn't like that a bit
and you go you go she just started
eating all these [__] dude and I'm like
here's the deal you can't see anything
no so this is all theater of the mind
you're listening to a Goddamn drugged
out radio play I can't see [__] no it's
all it's [__] fireside chat and I
don't know what part of you I'm supposed
to believe in that movie
I'm sure Ryan you're like she started
yes they got all this stuff and then I
thought
this
and then there's one nurse that you made
friends with yeah and she she would be
like she'd give you the like I'm with
you type look and stuff like that and so
then
we start hearing all this commotion and
I don't know what to believe from you
and not to believe and so I look out
over like the master in the photo I look
out over the messaging and there are
nine cops
[Laughter]
too short yeah there are nine cops and
all you're hearing is like well we got
to take her fast but we take it
Gray's Anatomy
she took all this and they're talking
about how they're gonna apprehend her
and take her down and also to be fair at
least four or five at least four or five
of the cops are like we don't need nine
like even they were like
you know but it did kind of stuff
strength you're gonna be dealing with
security came in first like nope she
took him now we got now we got now it's
a crime yeah now we have to call the
cops
we got to get you out here you just got
one tear and you're like yeah you got
nine mouths right now
I'm like well look at all of them
we gotta get you out of here because
you're waiting for a bed
they keep telling you tell me they're
gonna put me in my own room they've been
saying that since day one you can tell
me why I'm skipping too much people this
is Thursday
Ryan is in this place till Sunday
[Laughter]
is gone
Chandra but the funny thing about her is
I finally when I saw the Flesh and
everything calling when I called the
nurse in and I said hey I'm seeing like
[__] flesh fall off your face and
[__] she's like what and Chandra threw
the never saw what she looked like she
goes I'm seeing that too I go you're not
speaking up she's like oh my God I'm
tripping I said yeah you guys synced up
on your trip we did we were really good
it's like What Dreams May Come get this
[__] out of my Ivy and give me the oral
pills
and then I'm like asking you
I need
dick what do you need and you're like a
Diet Coke and I'm like okay
okay that I can do so this is this is
That's Thursday if whatever you yell at
me but on Sunday night they go and this
is where it starts to get real sad you
think it already no
Sunday night they go we gotta we got a
room for you and you go I mean I'm
leaving in the morning
why don't we take you up to I mean is
there any point and I go yeah there's a
point let's just get you to even if it's
just tonight because your bed was broke
it was bro it was broken
I couldn't even listen I didn't until
you said I was getting mad I'm like stop
moving and please that last nurse he
knew how to do it he got it yeah it had
like it like somebody made a crank it
had its own thing and it was broke so I
go hey even if I put you in this other
room right
at least you have one night in a good
bet and you're like all right we'll go
up there and so then we take you up to
uh your other room and that that was
even a process getting you into another
bedroom can I just keep my bed I know
it's broke but it's mine you're like a
marine with an M16 this is my bet there
are many like it but here's what I
remember when they tried to move me out
of my bed I know they bet me in half and
they said are you all right and I
remember saying no do I look all right
I'm not okay they were trying they were
trying they were trying but that's when
you told me that was the beginning of
recording things because you said
through all your experiences your mom
was a nurse for 40 years or and your
grandma was how old when she was in the
hospital
uh most recently the one where yeah 92
and what happened to her they dropped
her they dropped that's what you told me
when they're trying to swing me across
the
crosstalk
about me you roll back to the crab Feast
with me and you know I've never had a
three-way and people pee on my
sandwiches
myself and I hope one of my best friends
would too a nice person yes you're
absolutely but if you want to see every
single ounce of Midwest born on a farm
anger man drop my 92 year old grandma
yeah dude I don't want to see I'm like
wide open Tombstone you tell them hell
yeah you look comfortable when they were
bending me in half of them well that was
fine
you look just fine I do I knew I knew we
were in for the Long Haul so yeah we get
in that room now that's also the night
the Ravens are playing and we're doing
good and it half it's like perfect at
half time they're moving me yeah no I
remember see yeah that was one of my
selling points yeah do you remember
halfway from oh God all these things
halfway from gen pop to your uh solitary
cell they they forgot something and you
had to like my Walker yeah I didn't
remember that yeah
we're so close Stevie K we're so I'm
like we'll get there we're in the
hallway for like five ten minutes now
here's the thing we jumped over this is
the problem though and it's not her
fault the nurse or or maybe a nurse
practitioner orderly forgive me for not
knowing all the right rules who took you
she doesn't know you've been given a uh
special Walker that they want you to
have I don't know that you're on drugs
so like sometimes someone literally is
doing their job to the best of their
ability and things can still go wrong
just because of shift changes who told
this communication all that stuff
absolutely so yeah we get your room the
Ravens are jumping back real quick for a
second I'm on a Saturday they tell me
that I need to pass this physical
fitness test uh because I have a flight
of stairs getting in my you are maybe
gonna leave Friday that's it you were
maybe going to leave Saturn and they
were like maybe gonna leave Sunday you
gotta do this and I sit up and they're
like look you've been laying down for
like five or six days you haven't gotten
up at all just let's just see if you can
sit up and not get dizzy or whatever and
I I get wildly dizzy wildly and they're
like you can't do it today and I'm like
[__] and I just want to get out of there
so now it comes Sunday and you know what
else and you touched on this honey we
can't we can't skip this because it
becomes such a huge deal
you've got these that I told everybody I
had Factor five light oh sorry guys
you've got these uh
they look like reverse shin guards I've
got calf pumps on because you are you
are uh worried about your Factor five
you keep the amount of times you made me
adjust these mothers that ain't right
that didn't turn it now turn unplug it
hold it down it's gonna beat twice it's
literally I felt like you were walking
bag and you're like you're gonna be a
red wine do you cut the red wire and
count to three before you get to three
you need to cut that green one so you've
got these things and you're wearing them
and they're they're like compression
shin guards but not for your shin
they're for your calves yes yeah and so
these are a whole ordeal anytime you
move anytime I I need to tuck your sheet
for you and all that stuff and uh I
don't know why you made me keep blowing
you but they I just want to make sure it
worked that we were good friends
but uh you you would these you were very
conscious of these and you made sure
they're always on and not just on on
right and working because I was scared
to death literally yeah of death so when
you do physical therapy on Saturday and
they tell you you get through this
you're gonna be fine you have some sort
of physical almost seemed like
respiratory or something in your chest
setback
and now that's why you couldn't leave on
Sunday no so what happened on Saturday
yeah I sat up and felt weird and dizzy
yes I dropped back I'd lay back they're
like we're not gonna do it Sunday oh
look at we can see here we could see
your uh oh yeah there's my cat there's
my calf pumps yeah right there there
they are those are on wrong
are they no they're I mean they're yeah
they need to be spun they need to be
spun for sure they're all right but they
need to be spot okay
um so
um I fail I don't fail that day but I
don't I'm not allowed to take the test
on on Sunday I go to take the Walker
test again and I'm able to sit up fine
and this is all before the Ravens game
it was an evening game and I get the
Walker and they just had me literally do
a senior citizen Circle and I the guy's
like you did great you know that's it
for today and I'm I think he's joking
I'm like that's it he's like yeah you
don't want to overdo it trust me you can
overdo it and he goes tomorrow which is
Monday MLK day you have to pass stairs
test you perish your stairs test you're
out of here I'm like we're [__] out
of this [__] thank God yeah so I
leave you after the Ravens lose yep so I
get transferred into the room and that's
right when [__] Tyler huntley's
delivering pizzas over there handing the
ball out and the [__] lineman runs it
back and do you remember they were
taking my blood pressure and it was high
and you go you might not want to take it
right now and I was like yeah
for Jesus Christ that was also when I
brought you Wendy's yeah you did go get
one get one yeah you're always crazy
I go hey you want any food you're like
ah maybe I do
you want some Wendy's and you go oh my
God I was gonna say Wendy's
well let's talk about it because real
quick let's go to the next pictures here
Kirsten okay uh it's me in the hospital
here going back in that's my view now we
had this is a real meal that I was
served at Cedar Sinai Hospital here okay
I just want to say best medical care in
the world
not not the greatest food right uh but
homeboys getting tilapia and this is
what I'm getting this was a real meal
that was sausage a piece of French toast
syrup and a garnish okay that was
delivered to me this looks like you've
been bad do you know what these are well
I know look how many bites I took I
tried I tried one that is chick that
might be your bite those are chickens or
chicken tenders that's all right and
that's Jello back there do you remember
what I said I took a bite I go not
enough barbecue sauce in the world
did you eat that side salad
yeah I'd eat that yeah I'd take that
bread and I just rolled it over and I
would just dip it listen here's the
other thing I want to talk about that's
that's so and we could go on and on I'm
not going to about our health care
System but
the reason a lot of people end up in
hospitals is because of their diet and
we're going in there and trying to fix
that and they're serving your high
fructose corn syrup and everything else
in here this next one's my favorite one
this one right here
this right here man this is when I
finally got to a chair so that's me
finally taking a picture of a meal
across the room into my own bed there I
don't know if they're a sponsor but this
looks like an ad for better help this is
it
I asked for a grilled chicken sandwich
this is the bread they gave me a craft
single this is how you feed yourself the
crazy thing is by the end though you
were eating these craft signals like
yeah because look here's the thing I'm
not above a craft single I said this on
the Kelsey but sometimes but let me get
it
[Laughter]
[Music]
across the floor like it's wrapped don't
worry about it I gotta get up there I
just picture somebody whether it was
that one piece of French toast or this
piece of chicken that's like put
something else on that plate put some
pretty that up just a little doctor that
up a little bit so okay so Monday rolls
around Monday rolls me around rolls
around
and uh I'm just going crazy believe it
or not this is when things take a turn
this is I know we're not even
Monday rolls around and they dope me up
early in the morning and I'm I'm annoyed
because I don't want them to I keep
telling them I'm trying to cut back my
no you're fine every time I walk in with
me like you have a tail I'm like okay
I never knew what I was walking in too
so uh I go
the physical therapy nurse comes in
that's the other thing too about a
hospital you the one thing you really
need is rest and they're coming and
checking your vitals every three hours
pain meds every four there's people
coming to clean your room there's the
people coming to take your order for
food there's so many different surgeons
coming in and there's you never get in
rest you're never getting real rest so
um I say to this lady she's there really
early I go look they just gave me a
bunch of drugs and I really want to pass
this and go home today
can you do you mind coming back in a few
hours she's like I'll come back around
noon I'm like perfect I'll sleep for
three or four hours and then I'll be
able to pass the stupid [__] steps
test and she does she comes back but in
the meantime
I have this weird [__] experience
um where and this is before they gave me
the drugs because I want to be clear
about that
um where
I'm just laying in this bed and there's
this black figure at the end and it
doesn't look like a person or whatever
there's no not one detail I can make out
it's a silhouette-ish of a of a person
um and it physically grabs my right foot
with its left hand it's facing me I'm
assuming it is yeah and it Wiggles my
[__] foot like and then it moves off
to its left and it disappears and I'm
like what the [__]
and I know people like it's the drugs
it's the drugs maybe maybe it was sure
maybe it was but I was like regardless
of the thing it's a thing that you
experienced it is and it comes back to
me later so
um she comes back in to take the stairs
test and she's like how do you feel
today and I got I just feel weird I
can't put my finger on it but I feel
weird she goes do you want to do this
today I go yeah I want to get the hell
out of here it's been what now nine days
or whatever
and uh she goes all right so the
stairwells are locked so I brought this
little step stool thing here and we can
do this I'm like great so I go up and
down the stairs thing a couple times she
goes all right now I want you to
sidestep up it like you're holding on to
a rail in front of you can sidestep but
I do that and I come back down and she
goes well it's like sitcom time and
she's like well Mr sickler I can say is
your occupational therapist you have
passed the necessary tests
to be released today and I [__] fell
back on my bed and I said I'm clotting
she said what I said were you feeling
anything as she was talking yeah I'm
starting to feel that pain I felt before
in 2016 when no one told me what was
going on and I'm like boom on the bed
and I'm like I'm clotting and she's like
what I'm like I'm clotting so she calls
this doctor in what does it feel like
that's what he said I said it feels like
he's like an elephant I said three
elephants on my chest it's all the way
around her it's it's straight on
pressure down and it's fire on the
inside it's everything and you can't
breathe and he comes in he checks my
blood pressure and that's when he says
sir you might be having a heart attack I
said huh and he's like tell me what
you're feeling I said it's three
elephants on my chest my chest is on
fire and then I go oh my God here comes
[__] here it comes I said I feel the
pain in my jaw down my left arm I said
I'm getting a heart attack 101 right now
and he goes you might be clotting and
having a heart attack I said what and
then I black but we do need this bed
[Music]
you look over this uh blackout yeah
and when I wake up there's this nice
nurse there and I say am I going home
she's like your discharge has been
canceled today sir I was like [__] yeah
I don't know what's going on so Duffy's
there they wheel me to the CT scans and
when I get out they say
um all right you're you didn't have a
heart attack but you had a I guess it's
a cardiac incident I don't know my heart
swelled and they said that normally your
heart pumps two-thirds from the left
side one-third from the right yours is
pumping 50 50 and it's not supposed to
be doing that right
um and then they said you also have
massive pulmonary embolisms covering
both of your lungs now again I thought I
had a clot right and they're telling me
this and I was like yeah I think one of
the doctors said when I was there you
have extensive clots in both lungs yeah
which is that you had already heard this
you'd heard that from the other I was
just over there eating that crab single
again we already know that one so yeah
um
you know and I talked to Roy too we had
talked before about like disability
insurance and I said you know insurance
companies we're comedians they could say
well you can roll on stage in his
wheelchair he could roll up to that
table and podcast and they they
technically you could maybe if you could
yeah
um
but then one of the doctors comes in and
he's like look you this is serious
um and this is MLK day and I have four
different surgeons come in the room and
I believe you were there at least when a
couple of them said like you should have
died today yeah if you would have been
home when that happened and I think uh
this is what ends up becoming a more and
more realization for you of like this is
what my dad felt when it was like we
don't know what's wrong with you and
there's nobody else here and because if
you had been home by yourself
good luck [__]
it's amazing for as much as the you know
you had the clots from being in the
hospital so long right so you can't deny
that that that complication is probably
if not this whole cause of it but
had you left early
like
you better you better hope you're close
to your phone
because if you weren't like I don't know
even when I said that I said you know I
you're one of your surgeons said we
would if you had been home we would be
having a different day today yeah which
I think is kind of all you need a
surgeon to say yeah and um I said to him
you know it's a lesson too in life it's
okay to fail I mean I should know that
that's how we succeed as comedians it's
all by failure sure so I had never been
happier to fail a test in my [__]
life because if I do like you say I go
home a day early and I said the same
thing to him here I am I said I what I
felt today I definitely would have
called 9-1-1 he goes no that's when he
was like no you wouldn't if it had been
and then I got another one coming and
tell me you should have died today you
don't understand
right as it you don't understand that
they keep saying you keep saying you're
luck you're in a hospital but this
hospital has a particular program for
exactly what you're dealing with and you
come in with this [__] genetic blood
mutation so now you've become this very
interesting subject to them they want to
make sure you're okay so I get Now we
move off the spine [__] because they're
like [__] your back yeah uh we've got
lungs to deal with we've got blood we've
got heart and we've got
um oh what the hell is it because they
couldn't even oncologists came so they
start putting you on heparin
and they also tell you if this doesn't
start clearing up right away and let me
before you throw in your Factor five
drink they
they say well you do have a procedure we
go up through your leg and we can
essentially blast these but sunk them
out with a tube the size of your pinky
since you have Factor five we can't do
that because you could brain bleed and
be a vegetable I was like we're not
doing that right we're not gonna then
then just so everybody [__] knows
that option is off the [__] tape I
don't care this was supposed to put
that's the other thing is like you could
tell me that's a 98 percent
[__] uh positive procedure I just
[__] I'm the guy right now that's in the
.001 category of all of this so don't
tell me anything simple like I don't
want to hear simple I don't want to hear
[__] about my balls the only option
you'll take a 90 sure odds but
we also at this point are supposed to
have been here three hours that's right
three three hours and then it became
days and at this point we are two and a
half weeks
out into out of and more often into
hospitals yeah okay it's crazy enough
out there that weed shouldn't be sending
your world spinning ditch the paranoia
and take a toke of something low dose
and highly enjoyable that grass Harkens
back to the Mellow joints of yesteryear
to keep your soul light and your head
right that grass is legal organic
smokable hemp that relaxes your body and
Mellows your mind they're 100 organic
pre-rolled joints and flour very low in
THC and high in CBD so you can enjoy the
effects of CBD while keeping a clear
head if you're not looking to toke that
grass also offers the finest tinctures
and gummies on the market all the Mellow
goodness no smoke required all dag grass
products are federally legal for ages 18
and over and it ships right to your door
anywhere in the U.S look I just told a
friend of mine about this he's like man
I smoke some weed and it just sent me
over the edge I'm like you gotta go you
gotta go lighter dude check out that
grass so whether you're looking for a
new Buzz or a chill way to enjoy an old
favorite that grass will leave you in a
euphoric mood right now that grass is
offering my listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to dadgrass.com
honeydew go to daggrass.com honeydew for
20 off your first order that's
dadgrass.com honeydew now a back to the
do so that's when they tell me like you
need a week and a half a real
conversations you know it's touch and go
you could have a clock break off to your
brain you could have any one of these
could take you out and that's when they
say you know you could stroke and I was
like
it was weird but they just kept going
they're like a guy could come in here
with a knife
oh they start listing everywhere yeah
like if you lean against that window and
fall out you'll die from that too I was
like doctor doctor we don't need to tell
them everybody
stroke I was like well then I couldn't
[__] do my job if I had a stroke
right or ever maybe I don't know who
knows yeah what the [__] and you I mean
I believe in your resiliency but yeah
who wants you don't want you don't want
the question you don't want the
challenge no given the option you don't
want the challenge
and I have to have a real conversation
with my daughter's mother about [__]
life insurance and wills and all this
stuff and you know and she's like what's
going on I'm like it's not good like
don't tell Stella just keep it about my
back but this is what's going on this is
what's happening I'm calling Roy I'm
calling I call Kirsten I was crying I
was telling her I was like if I die you
did a really good job just so you know
you killed it you Duffy like it was and
she texted me she was like you guys all
set with pen pals
I'm just look I gotta be prepared Ryan
would respect that
I would
and um
I would be a footnote of a footnote
Farrah Fawcett you don't want to be fair
you want to in life but not in death
because she died if Michael Jackson got
this in the corner yeah and I think
somebody else died that day too and
that's how much we remember that but you
you uh I love this about you I think it
makes you a good comic I think it makes
you an even better friend and a great
person and a great dad you're you are
emotional you're an emotional person I'm
emotional too I don't even like being
sick like day two three and I'm of just
being on a couch and I like can't do I
get emotional from that stuff so you you
have that and also what we do for a
living you have to access how did I feel
about that now I can talk about it right
so we're kind of at that edge all the
time anyway for the type of people we
all storytellers and Comics
um creative types writers so
you also have that emotion you there's a
realistic element to being like hey I
need to make sure things are in order
but then there's the emotional burden of
I guess I have to make sure things are
in order now I know what my dad might
have felt like in the last few seconds
but I was in a hospital thank God and I
was only I'm only supposed to be here
three hours and this is what my
breakfast looks like there's not a lot
like I was joking earlier about Diet
Coke but there are little things that
make you feel better a little bit Ravens
game on bringing Sushi to the hospital
yeah you had it delivered outside people
running out to get it like I can't eat
this [__] anymore please help me I've
been here so long
so yeah you're right so much of it was
PTSD because
going back like my father was let out of
the hospital my brothers and I found
them dead in his bed in the morning
and we'll get to like the the timing of
being let out and stuff but
um so now I know what I'm I'm dealing
with and it's [__] scary as [__] and
you know uh I wake up the next day and
then the next day and can we show this
next picture like this is something
that's so [__] dumb but it's this dry
erase board right here and every day I'd
watch that lady change that [__] date
the 16th I was supposed to die the 17th
I see or the 18th and every day I'm
getting more emotional like okay we're
still here yeah shit's moving forward it
takes about five to six days they tell
me before my heart goes back to normal
size thank God they eventually weaned me
off the uh uh IV blood thinner and
they're shooting me in the stomach with
it
um before I get out
and then again I've got to pass all
these tests and
I don't remember
like some of the things that you're
gonna talk about but
um Roy hits me up and he's like hey
you're PayPal and random people what are
you talking about no I'm not he goes
look at your paper and I'm sending like
four dollars and 44 cents to this person
I paid I don't know who you are Kristen
but I paid some lady named Kristen sixty
dollars to babysit my daughter I'd say
you're a rando and she kept it good for
you
good for you goddamn 60 bucks a month
yeah you were
the last day I think was the day you
woke up with me in the room
and you were like hey you're you're in
here I go yeah because I told you I was
coming over and then you were just so
into and out of things and then you knew
that you wanted to like be as clear as
you could on the day that you're
supposed to get out but at this point
dude we've been in here weeks it's just
in this new room that you say we because
you were there yeah for real you thought
wow yeah I mean not I'd dude we have
been there for weeks yeah I don't I
don't like that was a thing for me too I
just kept being like I hate coming here
and I there's no way that I feel how
Ryan feels like you're not and every day
of like is today I'm gonna get out and
then and also every day there's a huge
chunk of this time where it's not even
about the back anymore yeah which is
wild too right the back is goodbye back
we'll come back to the back yeah yeah I
never got above 30 degrees right for a
month I'm laying there atrophy the whole
nine but but also the thing that's
frustrating me is any time now I'm being
so they're like look you're not leaving
this hospital until there's like 12
surgeons from all different departments
until they all say and I was like I'm
fine with that please yeah I don't want
to leave until everybody says yes and
every time it's if you notice something
different please speak up and I'll note
to something different and then they'll
come in they'll do a blood test and then
that blood test it'll be different and
then it's then I learned the system like
[__] now it's two more days and it's two
more days because they do the blood in
the morning it's 12 hours they get it at
night now you gotta fast for 12 hours to
do it again so you're on a two-day cycle
every time it's a setback and I'm just
getting more and more frustrated and I'm
also like I don't know if I'm gonna die
I don't know I don't know if I'm gonna
see my daughter again like all these
things start going through your [__]
mind like you know my kids all this [__]
am I going to be able to recover from
this you're also not even on the those
feelings and then the drugs of like face
falling off you're on steroids steroids
like crazy which alter your attitude
they can alter your emotional state they
can also alter your anger levels and
they did and they did right
I'm like
okay I want to say this first
I probably don't let's just say I dealt
with a hundred people 96 of them were
fan [__] and that's unbelievable odds
yeah it's in our Health Care system that
is ex Beyond excellent oh for sure now
there's always some [__] [__] and
I also say you know what they call the
person who finishes last in med school
doctor so it doesn't mean you're good at
what you do
and the thing about these nurses and
stuff is you never see the same one
either rarely they're coming in from
Pomona Montebello
you know I'm like God so every time you
got to tell your [__] story but you
can hear them getting downloaded out
there in their little shift change
because they're all doing a crossover
out there you can hear a download when a
new nurse comes non-stop but now they're
coming in to take blood and my veins
have been tapped so this one lady comes
in and she's hitting me here I [__]
hate this needle here I have good juicy
veins in the main ones but these side
ones hurt like a [__] just from
their time being in there no because I
get I do blood twice a month or twice a
year with my regular doctor and have
forever so I know I've got good veins
because these nurses always like I don't
even need to tie you off yeah but now
I'm drying up because every time I get
blood I just go like this and then they
just do it real quick that means
everything like your veins are angry
your veins are angry they kept saying
because they kept sticking them you're
getting stuck every day non-stop you got
one in in your arm always the IV so this
lady hits me once and misses it and I'm
just like
all right we all missed yeah hits me
twice
like you missed it again she's like I
did she's nervous don't swing at the
first pitch all right well let's not
miss it this time and she misses I want
you missed it didn't you and she's like
I go all right please just go get
somebody that knows what they're doing
real real quick because this is these
hurt yeah and that was three of them and
I'm not letting you have a fourth shot
and she goes okay and she pulls her
finger off I swear to God blood shoots
out I go well there goes the butt we
needed right there I go go just go get
somebody else this dude comes in now I
say you see this vein right here in my
arm here where the ivy is he's like yeah
I go look at this one over here in my
right arm you see how juicy that thing
is he goes yeah I go please hit that one
don't hit these small ones they [__]
hurt he goes okay
where do I feel them stick it right here
I go hey that's not the vein I just told
you can see an honest question why do
you think he lied well he answered oh he
said it was easier for me
that's what he said it's easier for me
and I said I don't give it I go but you
just told me you would do it here
he goes yup and I go you missed it and
you know and he goes I did twice once
that first that was his first one but
that's four total four total
hits me again and I go you missed again
didn't you he goes yep I go get the [__]
out of here get the [__] out of here
you're gonna go get somebody that knows
what the [__] they're doing oh for five
you're mad over five I'm fired up bro oh
for five
are you guys getting dared
somebody out there daring you guys she
comes in and they're there's their thing
says hematology on it yeah hematologist
their job is not to come do my vibe it's
just to get the blood yeah
and she comes in I go look I'm sorry
that's not indicative of who I am I'm
that's very frustrating she goes you
don't owe us any apology she goes you're
100 right to be pissed it is their job
they're not here to do anything but get
blood and it's embarrassing for me to
have to come in here and go behind them
so I'm sorry and she bang gets them
right away can you just take two she
goes I'm way ahead of you I'm taking two
for sure and she goes look I'm just
gonna tell you you have to be an
advocate for yourself in here if you're
not you're just you're a grain of sand
on a beach you know what I mean they
can't get to everybody
now
now I've got this [__] lady next to
me who's also a yeller she's all day in
two rooms next to my room and she's
running out yeah she's running out naked
they're telling me and stuff I miss this
entirely I didn't see it I'm on my back
but I just mean I didn't even know about
them yeah so you might remember it when
this so again now they put me back on
the Dilaudid because they're like [__]
your little flesh falling off you went
through some serious [__] and you're in
pain you need this yeah and I hear the
oh all right all day long well I finally
have a night of sleep and I hit
dreams again yeah I have this dream that
someone throws me into the back of this
like old Toyota Corolla and then starts
throwing bodies on top of me and I'm I'm
screaming and I know I'm screaming in my
sleep but I can't wake up I'm like oh
have you ever had have you ever had
sleep paralysis yeah one time you know
that's a figure a lot of people say a
figure at the end of the bed too that I
had to we'll get in that later
I'm like oh oh and they're burying me
alive in this car and I dig my way out
my back's killing me I'm crawling this
is all my dream obviously I'm I'm now
I'm outside the hospital and I'm showing
them my wristband
and uh I'm showing them my wristband I
can't get back in the hospital I finally
wake up I start buzzing that [__]
thing this lady runs what's the matter
you didn't hear me you didn't hear me I
woke myself up yelling I know I was
yelling she goes oh my God
was that you I go yeah
she was the lady that's been here so
they ignored it just ignored it I'm in
there screaming for my life and I said
listen
get these drugs out of here and stop
don't let me deep sleep please don't let
me deep sleep but I keep hitting these
weird deep sleep dreams about weird
people on Elm Street it's [__] it's
horrible I hate that [__]
um okay so this is like
you're in that room for over two weeks
right
that room alone yeah I spent almost the
whole I spent a month basically in the
hospital on my back and this and tell me
we had some pretty cool surgeons they
would come in oh yeah they would make
time for you the one guy he came in
crying for me and I go why what are you
doing you're not supposed to cry for me
and because every day he's the one
checking on me Tommy I'm going home
tomorrow and every day it's a major it's
not just a little bit he's like he came
in crying that first cardiologist came
in and I recorded it
he spoke to you for
I think it was like 38. I was gonna say
easy half hour he did it was over a half
hour I'm like I mean just a doctor give
you that amount of time he went over
everything with you and he came in and
he goes your friend the one who dunked I
go first of all how do you know
oh okay there he goes just let's say my
brother is a big fan of Comedy I go okay
dude yeah whatever you want but you also
had the one who was like smoke weed yeah
he was like Hey if that calms you down
and he ended up taking
um no what were they gonna give me it
was a pill it was um Xanax he said if
you don't he said we listen to our
patients and I can't believe he's like
you can already fly all of them said I
can fly and smoke marijuana no
cigarettes no Vapes no cigars right and
I was like how and they're like look we
don't want you to but if you're going to
it's not going to make your city because
if we're talking about cigarettes we'd
be having a completely different
conversation right now but we he's like
I don't you're fine yep you're fine yeah
and you know I think the the overriding
thing was how much you were not supposed
to be in there then how lucky you were
that you were still there when things
went bad thank God and then the
frustration of being there right
combined with everything you bring to it
because as we get older in life you get
closer and closer to your own mortality
and you want things to go right but you
also kind of hope they're going to go on
your terms and nothing about this
experience is on your terms and every
day it's something different happens and
every day I'm more and more frustrated
that now I'm here for two more days okay
I'm supposed to get out Wednesday
Wednesday like it's gonna be Friday
Fridays you're probably gonna be here
the weekend I'm like [__] [__] I've got
my dog at this lady Jackie thank you
this dog trainer who was supposed to
have her for three days you know my
daughter's mother's got my daughter the
whole time I'm not even getting to see
her and I'm freaking out about that like
I'm scared to FaceTime because I don't
want to see me all [__] up with oxygen
tubes and all that [__] and also you you
get to a point where like you know
people who sent you stuff to the
hospital yes it's very nice but I don't
to speak as you for a second you're like
I don't want to be in a hospital getting
nice things look at the [__] out of here
I don't want a thing another thing
delivered to this room and and like uh
there was a time to where I it got to
where with you where you would be like
I'm fine you don't gotta come by and
then of course I came by and it was
great but you you also don't want to
keep being the thing where you telling
people to come by like every the good
things feel bad because you don't want
them to have to need to happen and the
bad things feel bad because you're sick
of [__] doing them it's like you
can't it's hard to win it's a hard it's
hard to get a win yeah there were so
many people to some that visited so many
that called and were there for me I know
some people may not want their names
mentioned I'm not gonna just I also
don't want to forget anybody so I'm not
gonna say but there were some I mean AD
calls from out of the country people out
like it was wild Joe Coy offered to pay
my medical bills yeah he offered to pay
my medical bills he's like I got the
money I'm like I know I'm watching you
go through the [__] 12 trucks and the
five buses but I'm all right thank you I
love you do the podcast again
um but
the other doctor was like there's always
one patient you would remember I go do
not tell me I'm about to be he's like
you're the one I like I don't want to be
the one right put me in the top 10 bro I
don't want to be the number one he's
like you're number one I go give me
another one though that you stand out
and he goes okay and this is something I
dealt with so you're on these pain meds
and I haven't [__] for for
15 days I get up to and they're like you
gotta go and I'm like yeah I want to go
you've been giving me all these [__]
stove softeners it's not working give me
the [__] the little bullet I'm gonna
put it up my ass to suppository well I
think nurse is going to do it she's like
no you're doing it I'm like what
so she Lubes this thing up excessively
and I put it up there and I'm thinking
you know I'm gonna get one of these
power dumps and it's disappointing it's
a two-parter but I finally go and he
tells me like it's good that you went
because this one patient same situation
as you didn't [__] for three weeks
we are checking them out that day and I
say listen I want you to just just go
before you hit the road the guys driving
from LA to Fresno which is a few hours
yeah and he's like I'm as your surgeon
I'm not comfortable discharging you and
he's like I'm going he's like then
you're going on your own because I'm
telling you you should really go just
before you get in the car he said the
guy doesn't get farther than walking out
of the room into the little Corridor and
he collapses they call him he goes get
an ultrasound on his stomach right now
they do and dudes ABS [__] split open
because he had [__] and now he's back in
the hospital with a hole ripped open
abdomen
ah
oh my God It's gotta be number one
so
anyway
the Mantra from all these I'm seeing
like I said I'm a lab rat this year I
gotta go see pulmonologist oncologist
cardiologist I gotta go see the spinal
specialist I gotta go see all these
people
but the one guy I was talking about uh
Tom he's like don't feel bad your friend
the one who dunk he did something stupid
and I just started dialing he goes you
you did nothing wrong he goes he was
funny but stupid you did nothing wrong
and he was awesome and they're also
they're all young guys yeah and girls
ladies I should say excuse me men and
women they are young and I'm like God
damn and I like that better than the old
[__] way of that's just this it's
just it's just that these people really
want to [__] figure out Solutions and
stuff so they're telling me every day if
I see something different I have to say
something you see something you gotta
say something
we're finally coming to my last day yeah
this is the day you're supposed to leave
this is the damnedest person I'm there
yeah and I do have another incident
there's one day where I have another
incident where I think I'm having a
heart attack oh yeah again and I'm I'm
punching a bit I didn't know the beds
had alarms on them but I'm punching the
bed and I've lost my patience at this
point because now we're three and a half
weeks or whatever in and I've listened
to every [__] druggie yell I've
listened to Lady eat pills I've listened
this thing over here and now I'm like
you synced up your trip I'm just yelling
get just put me the [__] out they're
like sir calm down I said if I could
[__] calm down I calm down like
something's happening it comes all the
way I mean tilapia
you get in there a month I'm like Kevin
it's alive start screaming for tilapia
too
I finally I asked them for the Dilaudid
Ivy I'm like just [__] knock me out
this pain isn't excruciating I'm
recording it trying to play it back and
and I got by the way I'm wearing a
[__] eye mask I've got earplugs in
plus soundproof headphones over it I got
a sound machine on my phone not the
Miami one either bro just the regular
old style machine right here next to my
head
and they come in they kick your man
because you can't either price of my
name ten times
so it's the last day and I finally can
[__] on my own okay so after a month and
I go in and I should hold on dude I'm
there right yep you're there this is not
just that okay so we're getting I have a
show that night and there's nothing
worse than being than knowing you have
to leave your friend
because and I knew it too I [__] knew
it that it was gonna work out that you
were gonna because your thing was like
hey just stay here until I'm good and I
and I was pushing the time on it and you
can laugh about this now in the moment
who you you're and I mean this sincerely
your compassion for where I need to be
who [__] cares right you've been in
this place for weeks so I don't expect
you and I feel guilty being like hey I
gotta go do something that you can't do
for a while yeah man you're still gonna
be here I'm not leaving you at your home
I'm leaving you here
and so
they're saying oh we're going to bring
your medicine and you are at your Wit's
End you're roid it out you're you've got
You've Got Drugs still in your system
but you don't want to take the new drugs
because you want to be as clear ahead as
possible for when you leave because if
you can't go to the bathroom if you're
too out of it they can't let you leave
within a certain window of having given
you these drugs which also means your
pain is up right so everything's kind of
like crusting at the same time and I am
skipping as much pain meds as I can
because they are [__] me up and so
this is when I was in there when you
woke up and so then we get to like I
think I had to leave
I had to leave at like 3 30 and then I
end up like I'll wait till four with you
and then right around four the doctor
comes in so they're like well I'm not
leaving now right the doctor's here and
I want to make sure that Ryan has
somebody else who understands what
they're saying whether I record it and
send that to Duffy or somebody else or
cursing whatever it is and so then um
there he goes and he's like I'll come
back and you're like I just want I just
don't want to leave here not knowing
anything and they're like they're gonna
make sure you can leave when you're
comfortable
so then um
the nurse comes in the new one and says
can I have a Russian one I'll give you
all your stuff and you were like I'm
still coming down for these drugs can
you give it to me later and she says
yeah that's fine he's like I just don't
want to be and this is how because that
is what they do when you also when you
wake up in the morning like hey we know
you're just waking up fresh at five
o'clock here in the morning
bumpers out of your mind from drugs
we're gonna give you some real important
information about medications you've
never heard of and don't know [__] about
but you also people get mad at me too
like I'm like what's that one like
Eliquis tell them to start and I'm like
I don't know this [__] I don't know it
but you also were maxed out like you
were saying stuff that would never
happen you're like I don't want anybody
throwing a brown paper bag at me it's
saying take these yeah and I was like
and you know I want to be like Ryan shut
the [__] up they're not gonna do that
but you are so kind of like you know out
of it right I'm not taking tilapia pills
all right so she's like yeah we're not
gonna do that and even when the doctor
came in you were like you were like I
need to know it he's like yeah well yes
we'll do it you know you said I remember
this he said what are you worried about
I said dying right because I know that
but what are you worried about after
that I go Claudia and dying we got it
yeah the candle's burnt down here so
then you go you go hey dvk and I'm like
yeah and you're like I'm gonna sit up I
go okay and I haven't seen you move
and I go what [__] does this
take a picture in my back for me and I'm
like okay I don't know what I'm gonna
look at right I hadn't even seen the
photos we saw her oh you hadn't no when
it was all bubbling up
a reverse alien by the way that that was
nothing it got it started to look like
an IV bag in my bag yeah
yeah so uh you're like I'm gonna need
you take uh take pictures so I go okay
no problem I'm like it's of course right
so I take a couple photos for you and
then you go all right I think I'm gonna
I think I'm gonna [__] I go you're there
and you're like no in the bathroom I go
do I have to go with you and you're like
no I can do it I go okay but I want to
say this too also for a guy like once
you have to [__] like you forget how
much we take for granted the ability to
get free quickly and hustle to a toilet
I'm over there in a bit I got a lot it's
called a log roll I got a long roll and
I gotta sit up I gotta wait like 20 or
30 seconds to make sure I don't get
dizzy
give it a couple of those right yeah I
gotta breathe out can I go I'm breathing
in this [__] thing like and honestly
if I can just get up and take my Walker
to the toilet and back that's a [__]
huge day for her it's a huge day for me
because what you also knew experience
this later on you'll probably touch on
it is how much your muscles have
deteriorated it's killing me yeah so
so then I go okay you're gonna go in
there like yeah and I'm like
I'm still feeling bad because I gotta
leave right and so I go what can I do
for you you're like you could put all
that stuff together right and uh half of
it's mine
so
so you and I have been friends with the
moment we met at the Bridgetown Comedy
Festival and I think 2013 maybe 2014 at
the latest but I bet it was 2013.
and uh
uh so we're in our 10th year of being
friends okay
I'm
I'm on the far side of the room across
from me is your your bathroom and in
between me is the bed you are sitting on
the bed facing your bathroom and I go do
you need anything and you and Ryan's not
gonna be going nope and I look over and
you stand straight up and two little
wrecking balls come swinging
[Laughter]
I'm just watching your car dice just
[Applause]
[Music]
click click click
and I'm like
we're friends now
in the rear view mirror if your dick
just these two
swinging oh it looks like two old people
on a porch
oh I believe you too because when I
would sit on that toilet they would
definitely dip in the water yeah
everything
loosened up in that bed
he started walking
yeah dragging yourself and then you go
into the bathroom and then the door
opens right
hey uh where did Mr sickler go I'm like
he left he's in the bathroom
and uh okay
um he's he's doing all right her and I
are speaking to each other as though you
can't hear everything we're saying yeah
it's a the room is like an eight by
eight it's the size of the studio right
and I go uh I go he's he's there in the
restroom oh okay well all of his
medicine is ready are you the one taking
him home and now I know I need to be
clear here right I go I am not taking
him home so all the information you need
to give him you should wait until the
next friend of ours gets here and she's
like okay
uh I'll come back then
and now you're still in the restroom
right and enough time goes well I packed
everything I go right like yeah and I'm
like I felt like I was uh Brad Pitt and
uh the bear Jew
Daddy yeah uh I go uh right yeah you're
good I'm good I'm like okay so then I'm
not
five minutes goes by not a lot of time a
lot of time in a bathroom right
uh she walks again and she goes is he
still in the bathroom and I don't want
to be mean to anybody but I want to be
like is he in the bed but am I dancing
this is the lady we're dealing with yeah
so he is he still in the bathroom and
and I said uh I said yeah he's still in
there and then
uh she goes okay well I just wanted to
give them all stuff I got totally
understand trust me nobody wants to go
home more than Ryan but uh uh as soon as
he's out of there I'll let you know and
then right around this time you go oh my
God I don't want to make it funny but I
don't remember it was something like
you're like you're like hold up
her and I
like each other
and you're like well I don't know what's
happening now and I'm like what is it
right and you're like oh man hold up
before you say this
what I see
yeah I know isn't serious
in the medical world sure
but but I'm told let's add everything up
anything I've never seen before or
things different at all I am to report
it right but I am having second thoughts
about reporting it before I even say
hold up because I want to [__] go
home and I'm literally scared again that
if I report this it's another two
[__] and everything's multiple
levels yes you want to go home you also
know the last time you went home you
ended up coming back here you also know
that if you had gone home too early the
last time you might not be here in a
bathroom and I would have never got to
see your little hangers okay yeah so
also you know about what happened to
your father right and you also know the
the number one person who you're trying
to stay alive for right all and you want
to go home all these things are
happening to you plus you're on drugs
plus you're in pain plus you're on roids
so even the roids alone takes off you
know every cars have Governors on them
for anybody who doesn't know Governor it
may say 150 on your dash but that
[__] is not going past 115. it
because it has a governor on it so your
Governor's off or at least not as
effective for emotions this is what
happens to people with PTSD which by the
way you also are going through traumatic
things for yourself right you're seeing
shapes when you don't think you're high
yes so uh
uh you say uh you say you know hold up
and yes you do want to leave but I'll
let you tell this part of what what
happened well in there so I see blood in
my stool right which is and it's red
blood so I know it's not that big of a
deal
in the medical world however my meds
have been changed there's so much going
on I even said to her at first like I
don't know what it what it is I'm maybe
it's a hemorrhoid right but did I push
too hard and [__] my back like I don't
know what's going on so what I would
love is a second opinion and preferably
from someone anyone of the multiple
people who've been dealing with me and
this lady got upset well she first said
it's not a big deal yeah she's trying to
downplay it yeah yeah which is not which
I should be sitting either by the way I
think sitting here right now at this
table you probably would lean more
towards right like okay all right if you
really think so if you're gonna but
you'll still check with somebody but
this tone this attitude I have I don't
know that go talk to me after that many
weeks in the hospital and see if I'm
still keeping this timber in my voice
so so then
you are lacking I'm gonna tell you as I
love you you are lacking the ability to
Grant her as much grace as you normally
would fair enough okay yeah she is
lacking the ability to use the right
words to make you understand that she is
gonna do the right thing and once these
two ships missed the dock neither one of
you could get back to Rocky Drago all
over I guess
right it is you couldn't get back and so
she then what then we also find out I'm
now in a room with two stubborn people
and you are I have decided you are not
here to help me so go get me someone who
is just a second opinion from somebody
on my screen right she has decided I'm
gonna make this guy understand that I
know what I'm talking about which she
may she did right but you could no
longer hear that and she could no longer
go
like if she had gone hold on I [__] up
I'm not saying I [__] up or did
anything wrong I'm just saying I [__]
up in the way I made you feel I didn't
even need that I just need all I needed
was like I'll go get somebody but to be
fair to that's it you can't even say
right now if that would have worked but
I think it would have been a better test
if she would have said I'll get somebody
for you right now it definitely would
have worked because it's all I want both
keep talking right and uh
she go you go just stop well hold on
hold on I also say I understand what
you're saying but the one thing I'm told
is that if I see anything different I'm
to speak up about it and this is
different and you this is your first you
know time I've seen before she did the
digging you were angry enough and I love
you but I I'm gonna do it to that camera
right there I go
I mean dude I come from divorced fans so
I'm used to I'm used to trying to trying
to get off first and steal second at the
same time
I'm like I'm like
uh I have a line in my new hour talking
about somebody else where I go he gets
like this that's what I was like hey hey
hey
so
uh so she like has me look but then by
the end of it I was like okay
I have my own trauma from people yelling
right so I did not like that but I also
knew
you were coming from a place of
fear
and caution fear being the biggest which
will come in in about 30 seconds in a
real way
so
she leaves right and then she goes and
gets the charge nurse and now and this
is so crazy it's not the right word it's
just we're just so close right but we do
need to know what this is right
so she leaves
and you go you go go in there and look
at that [__]
no I asked you to look at that I did not
did I took a picture
oh you think you took a picture
I go what dude go look at you tell me
there ain't blood in there oh okay so
that I I walk in anyway you see that
blood
you're back I'm the best now
but I'm like I also like that you're
making I'm yelling at you it's literally
it's true it's right it's true you are
like you're all right you see that blood
and I was like I just need to know are
you and Mom gonna stick it out or
is this my call what I do do I need to
go hide under the piano again so so
I go uh
oh God I go I go yeah you go come here
and I go back in there you go take this
phone take pictures of that [__] for me
what
I wanted to be like no
I went from I need to go to a show
sway like a Tay in the way like Nell
so now I'm taking pictures of my
friend's [__] and it's not even for a
prank
so then I take this I take the photos
for you and I'm like we have derailed
here we are so close and then uh I'm
also by this point so everybody knows
I'm standing there with all my stuff
like my back because I gotta go in some
of mine and I can't and I feel horrible
because I also don't want to leave you
and I and in your shoes there's no way I
wouldn't feel you did never say this you
never put this on you never indicated at
all but there's no way I wouldn't feel
somewhat like you had you had to go like
you had to go Daniel I know but that
we're both caring people so uh
so I stand there charged nurse comes
back in she's like so we
um I heard we had a little bit of an
issue and you go oh we did
Ben you you turned and you were like
look
I've been I was supposed to be here
three hours I didn't want to be here I
didn't want to be here longer than that
it took forever to do it I had to come
back here I was supposed to be gone in a
day then two days then the day after
then the day after the day after and
then I got here then the day I was
supposed to go home and you you walked
it through and you go no one wants to
leave here more than I do okay I'm sorry
for being upset I didn't feel like I was
being heard with what I was saying all I
want is for somebody to look at it I
appreciate her looking at it so that she
can get the right person but I didn't
need to be told what it was or what it
wasn't I just needed somebody on my team
who's been dealing with me to come look
at it because my dad died and I woke up
one day and he wasn't there and I mean
look right I'm watching you right and
you got you go I apologize for being
emotional and that's when you saw
you the anger which I will put on the
the drugs and the frustration and the
fear and all that yeah all of it that's
when that was able to take because in
that time you took a few breaths because
I wasn't saying much to you because I
wanted you to just let it go sometimes
people think in these scenarios they
should like chime in and sorry like
that's the worst thing you can do
somebody let them get it out just let it
get it out and then don't it's like a
seizure just don't move away don't yeah
it's a good it's the best time to not
yes and don't anything don't know and
either just go I hear you I hear you and
uh that allowed you to then let what was
really going on it is a serious you do
want that looked at but also what's
behind all that and what what you felt
when you saw it right because you'd be
like mother
right that's what I'm I'm in there for
30 seconds because I'm like I know that
black stole means there's blood in my
stool but this is red I've had this
before like but do I [__] say do I
regret not saying something and going
home and they're like well did you
happen to book [__] blood when you were
here I'm like yeah but you didn't say
right and so that allowed it for you to
then come here's what here's what it is
Miss and uh
she said okay
um well I will have someone on your team
and go that's all I ask for and then she
walked out that's when I looked at you
and I said that was really well said you
said really well done right yeah good
yeah
thank you your cheek fell off Daniel
right right right
it's so uh and so then um then the
surgeon showed up I go what are you
doing here he goes because I heard you
were having problems and he [__] told
everybody in that room Ryan's right this
man was told if he sees something
different to report it he did I'm here
to tell you that I think it's okay
however it's your call do you want to
stay here again tonight or do you want
to go home and I was like I want to
[__] go home if you're saying that's
all right I want to go home he's like
great you can go and you said that to me
I know you actually this is one of the
things you said in that to that person
to you nobody wants to get out of here
more than I do and I know that you guys
need this bed because there's probably
somebody in the room where I was insane
they can't wait to be up here and I want
them to have the opportunity I had to
get the best that's true that's who I am
yes yes yes but you would you would lock
back in to that point right which was
good and to be expected and you didn't
call anybody any names you didn't do
anything violent or anything like that
but you had hit your limit and I just it
was just two ships missed the dock they
were supposed to hit at the same time I
just gave her a firm stop I gave her one
of those and she was like all right I
think I won't stop I was like [__]
stop stop yeah
um and then they let me out yeah a few
hours ago if he takes me home yeah dude
when I when I went downstairs and he was
waiting to get checked in
the relief to make it about me the
relief that washed over me that I I'm
literally this is a track meet and I'm
I'm literally getting I don't I don't
have to set the Baton down and hope my
trackmate track track team member comes
and picks it up it yeah I handed it to
him right when I go hey he's up there
just this is just what he's going
through stuff like you know he just
found this they're waiting to find out
and so that felt great too to be able to
like okay because I hated leaving you
and then yeah you got to go home he took
me home yeah like nine or ten it was
late as [__] and uh I was scared
literally to death to go to sleep yeah
and he slept over and we watched a
little bit of The Comedy Store doc I
remember I got up I didn't I got up out
of my bed at like five in the morning I
was so hungry he's poor dude sleeping
he's got to go to work I'm microwaving
these pizzas they're you're not supposed
to microwave it was bricks I just didn't
care anymore do you you have more photos
from any of that other stuff I'll show
you some other stuff
um
but the real PTSD hit me because my
father same situation got out on a
Wednesday night Thursday was
Thanksgiving we went home for the
weekend Friday Saturday so what I really
didn't tell a lot of people if any more
than one
is uh that that's Sunday night was the
night I was really scared of because I
was like
this is the [__] night this is the
night he went to bed and when we found
him dead in the morning and so that one
I don't think I got to bed till like
four or five that day and then my sleep
was all [__] up for a while but I got
out I
um yeah let's look at some of these
other pictures what we got coming up
here Kirsten let's see
because I want to thank God there's my
stepson this six foot five [__]
that was a beast and took me everywhere
yeah and did everything that's my
daughter right there she came up and
finally they let her come up after some
BS went down let her see me and she
decorated my Walker right there kept me
comfy right there
um that's from ymh I want to say thank
you Tom Christina nadab Annie everybody
down there from the ym ymh crew there's
so many people I'm I'm missing two of
them potential that's how I rolled out
right there I had my night pants the
whole time in there
and uh there I am when they finally said
I could [__] go
and then that's my right before my
haircut the first time right there but
look how much Slimmer you are from that
first from that Friday yeah that's the
other thing too you were like posting on
social media like you posted before you
went in I was like hey finally happening
and then I did it even said hopefully
see y'all on the other side hopefully
and then where's my haircut and I got a
haircut look at look at me right here
all cleaned up after that one not that
one that's the next one yeah there we go
that's my first haircut and then this is
me right here on my Walker fresh out of
the hospital they told me I had to walk
that's me going around the pool
and my night pants right there that was
a big adjustment for you to realize how
hard it was just man I thought I'd be
able to do two laps around that pool
without a walker that's my second one
right there and I'm using the Walker
because what you spoke to earlier the
atrophy like I don't have an ass my
hamstrings are [__] rubber bands my
neck hurts so bad from holding my
[__] big ass head and when I first
came back to the studio to record my I
didn't know what it was I was like what
is going on it was my own shoulders like
pulling me down and just [__] uh on
the neck so
um so many people uh can't tell you how
expensive these [__] go support
my my special Lefty son uh on YouTube
there's a lot of messages you probably
see you'd have to go back through your
phone I mean you're talking about weeks
of being listen to me I remember people
reaching out to you and you're like oh
you know I heard from today you know
what I heard from today so many people
so it was so [__] nice and again I
don't want to forget the Love on social
media man all your all your hard so many
names to throw out there but because you
posted on you're like I'm remember when
you went back after the three hour
debacle you were like wasn't supposed to
be like this and then you kind of went
silent for weeks yeah I'm not the guy
that does all that no I probably should
be probably help with followers and all
but I don't really want to live like
that I I sat there like it felt very
pandemicy to me in a way where I was
stuck at home and I watched everything I
signed up for bet plus like I signed up
for so much [__] to watch and I watched
all of it then I just you know you start
to see like oh it's everyone's version
of True Crime comedy drama you know
whatever
um but I've always said the one thing I
wanted to be that my father never was
was an old man and and I'm trying my ass
off to get there
um
it was also really hard for me too like
I'm a hustler I'm not used to like
laying still I can't that's been very
hard and the other thing that gives you
PTSD too is when my dad died like there
were so many nice people that just
bought clothes for us and sent them over
and I just remember feeling like a
[__] loser I felt like uh when you
were a kid yeah 16 I felt like this
charity case and I didn't I was like
[__] that I was also so mad that the one
parent who really loved us just died
right
um so even now like people brought food
over
um people've come over yourself you came
and hung out me and Stella playing uh
she's [__] Crazy Eights shoots in
love with your daughter's ass oh yeah
but she got you a Crazy Eights bro
you watch football with us but you know
I don't like asking somebody to get up
can you please give me the ice pack can
you you know go make me a drink I'm I'm
been on my own since I'm 16. so I don't
know how to do that and it's very
it's very humbling to have to do that
it's very and it makes me feel like that
charity case
to make me take pictures of that [__]
yeah it was hard for me to ask you to do
that dude
so but no but it's a those are
experiences those are growing
experiences I wanted to end this with
first of all I love you love you too
thank you for everything no it's not a
question and there's been some uh
some fun articles that have been written
about this that one that popped up that
made me laugh because it that's a
picture of me okay you're just loading
again it's a picture of me oh there it
is from my stepson's graduation so I
don't know why they I don't know it's on
my Instagram but it this is why you
shouldn't believe [__] that you read
okay it starts off with American
professional comic author and performer
named Ryan comic sickler
went to a close by grade school for his
essential training moved on from that
point afterwards signed up for a
secondary school in his old neighborhood
none of this none of that's right okay
so this is supposed to be in Baltimore
this is an article about me who I what
I'm going through from the perspective
of some of being from that area yes okay
uh Ryan began uh wait wait starting my
uh his most memorable video was named
Colt man they put us an L in that
[__]
[Laughter]
excuse me um
so it says Ryan Sickler's back now I
also made a joke saying I'm finally
going to get a backyotomy and a
backiotomy is a joke that Dave Chappelle
makes in Half Baked raising doctor said
I gotta get a baggy out of me so I just
put that out there okay
Ryan Sickler's back a medical procedure
Ryan ex oh this is that's the title Ryan
expounded on his second crisis uh blah
blah blah where is it oh backyotomy
frequently alludes to a careful
procedure expected to change the life
structures of a patient they're saying I
went in the medical clinic Ryan sickler
is preparing
for his backyotomy dude these [__]
idiots I persevered it says through to
horrifying torment for a considerable
length of time blah blah blah this is
probably written by a 15 year old who
knows yeah or some [__] so uh they
they said the same thing we don't know
not much is really known about his
condition now this is my condition I
just started physical therapy yesterday
um I got a long [__] year ahead
of me and and what I didn't know about
blood clots is you know I'm on blood
thinners for life now but
I didn't know that I lived with these
clots until your body gets rid of them I
I was surprised to hear that I thought
it was kind of demon too yeah I thought
the blood thinners would get rid of but
they said it could be up to a year
um so yeah I'm gonna take things a
little slow I'm walking 15 minutes a day
and I'm literally doing Sidekicks and
and knee raises a lady came in my home
to to teach me this [__] so uh how do
you feel
I feel great now I feel like you know
I'm driving again I watched my daughter
like the first night I got home and like
she laid in bed with me and was just
like man like I would have missed all
this and now we you know my daughter's
been missing me like when she came to
see me she went crazy like I I surprised
I had Kirsten take me to her school to
pick her up
and she had no idea I was coming to get
her and she ran out to me she's like Dad
you're okay and like gave me this huge
hug and just on Friday like the other
thing that I love too is like all of us
like I love that I rolled a dice on
myself I have a schedule now that I
create yeah you know I don't have a nine
to five where I can't go see my
daughter's play or I gotta feel guilty
about missing work because of this or
stay later because I missed this two out
whatever it is and they had this
creative writing exercise where you
could come and the kids could read to
you and she you know I didn't tell
anyone I was coming she her mom was
already working she wasn't expecting
anybody and I showed up man she [__]
ran up to me she's like I miss you I
love you oh my God we sat down and read
and I was like this is what my daughter
needs this is what I [__] need you
know so right now my focus is Health
recovery because it's going to be a
minute before I'm back did the surgery
take
I realized yesterday when we were
talking I really don't even asked you
until the pain is gone from physical
therapy I really won't know I don't I
mean it's sore because it's I haven't
rehabbed it so I don't know we're not
all swollen out and everything no it's
it's flat down now and uh and that's why
they want me to wait one more week and
they might send me to a facility to do
physical therapy and work out there but
it's it's going to be a few times this
year I'll be back starting in uh end of
May we're gonna just start doing like
one a month in May and June and then I
think we'll do a couple every two weeks
and see how that goes okay good but I
gotta build a new hour because I've
dropped my hour coming up here in a
couple weeks Lefty son on my YouTube and
I will get you dates and all that and
we'll get tickets right on the website
anybody who saw it live saw me Crush you
did Crush dude I'm just setting it up
for you can I ask you before we roll I
know we went longer I have no idea
that's okay but um
from a
what you touched on about
you know the fears about
being an old man unlike your father or
the fears of like how close you touched
it and and uh and and you know this dark
figure that you said even came back
another time and like
and also the 16 year old kid who was
really angry and then was forced and I
was I'm happy to force you to do it I
would force you to do it again as much
as you needed to accept
um
generosity to accept service right did
is anything lingering from any of those
feelings in a positive way that you feel
like I I I should and I can be there's a
difference between being in a derogatory
term a charity case and being somebody
who allows people to be there for them
yeah to to love them yeah I've always
said that what I just want is love and I
realize that I don't also know how to
accept it you know what I mean like so
many people
that's the other thing too like you got
to let people be who they are some
people don't know how to look if I
wasn't me in that same situation I don't
know what I would have done or said or
sent I would have certainly done
something
um but each person has to do it in their
own way what they're comfortable with
you don't know what someone else's
trauma might be like they might be like
look I just can't go to hospitals it's
been this thing for me where everybody
you know whatever it doesn't make me
better than anybody that's not why I say
this but like I've lost people in my
life to cancer where you watch them go
yeah right and and then there's always
those like Peaks and valleys of like
good for a little bit now we're back in
here now we're good for them and we're
back in here and that was a hard thing
for me uh coming back into those
hospitals and it's all taupe and beige
and the steriles it can be while also
seeming gross at the same time and in
certain ways and the food in the
cafeteria and and all those things but I
don't say that to say anything good
about myself but you that is that is
something that people
can give you in whatever way they can do
you know what I mean that is and for
some people they can't do that for some
people it's hard to do that some people
don't think anything about it and as
long as everybody comes with what the
love that they have to give it doesn't
mean it's always the love you need at
that moment or the best type of love but
at least it's true and honest and then
it's on you
to accept that you know what I mean
because I went a couple there were a
couple times I was like he is not
telling me
so Ryan is not
cannot answer the phone right now
because he doesn't want to
every stick of it or he's the first one
to say to me come here the first time in
my life I didn't even know how to do it
I had to ask Sarah wine shank how to put
my phone on silent and I turned that
[__] off for like three days why
I just didn't want to hear you know
there was so many people also when you
have to tell your story every time to
somebody else that calls like and I'm
not complaining about it I had so much
love I had family call friends call you
know loved ones whatever they all were
calling or checking or texting or
messaging like there's so many people so
if you reached out in any way family
friend foe I don't give a [__] thank you
very much yeah yeah it does make a
difference so you know it's interesting
too though I I hope I don't know how to
accept love I gotta learn I bet you can
in certain ways you know they have those
five love languages Rory and I just did
them yeah I know mine and but I wonder
if you're one of your least ones is acts
of service and you have a hard time
accepting that type of life you're
feeling good about it and you found
yourself in a position where I like to
be the one that does that sure you know
you found yourself in a position where
you needed to get it and uh you know I
think you asked for it in the right ways
I think you advocated for yourself and I
think that you did what you needed to do
to still be here and I'm glad you are
buddy thank you brother I love you thank
you
um plug and promote everything again
please don't people town and then uh pen
pals you can also uh watch that on
YouTube both those actually and then
um everything else is danielvankirk.com
Myself and Irene too who's a great comic
we have a show that was running here
weekly run a bit of a Hiatus so that'll
be coming back and
everything's there I'm sure I'm
forgetting something but you see me
around just go to danielvangers.com I
love it same on Instagram at Daniel Van
Kirk
um as always Ryan sickler and let me say
this we're going to get links up for the
tour dates the specials coming we'll be
promoting [__] out of it don't even
worry uh as always Ryan sickler on all
social media Ryan sickler.com we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign